hey everyone and welcome to another
episode of generation next
it's been a huge week sony had another
press conference
finally revealing the price and launch
date of the playstation
5. now honestly going into this event i
did think that sony was kind of on the
back foot a little bit
xbox had one hell of a week so we're
gonna run through the event and kind of
chalk up how well
sony has done joining me to help me out
is playstation
digital edition to more hussein
absolutely quivering with excitement
i hated that i
hated that
and playstation 5 disc
edition jordan
was stretching this job digital to damn
well because tam is the one is the most
online of all of us
he's very online no that means well i'll
take it let's say
you say so you go viral on twitter all
the time so i'm assuming that's just
what it means okay
i i like it hi jordan
all right let's run through the event
and uh kind of answer the question
has sony done enough
intro
let's start with price and obviously
microsoft
uh coming out with very very competitive
pricing for the series s
and the series x uh sony's response
today so the digital edition of the
playstation 5 is going to be
400 bucks and then the version with the
disc
tray is in at 500. um
honestly i think the pricing especially
on the digital version is very very good
disc version though i don't know if i'm
ready to pay an extra
hundred dollars i don't really know what
i'm getting out of that it's not
immediately as clear to me
it's it's i think it was probably a
little higher before microsoft dropped
their bombshell
um it was probably if i had to guess
maybe like 450
more maybe even like 480 or something
like that and then
um like serious conversations were had
in
in the sony um camp and then they came
to dropping it down a hundred dollars
um i think we talked about this during
our pre and post show but
i think ultimately they are probably
taking a bit of a loss
but what they're gaining is um one a
cheap console that continues momentum
for them
and two they hook people into an
ecosystem
that keeps them there and like i said it
on that post stream
two games two game purchases that's all
it takes one game purchase given the
price of demon souls that's seven
bucks yikes yes the rumored 70
price tag for next-gen games is true at
least in some
cases xbox as of recording hasn't we
we're not really sure we know that some
ubisoft games are going to be the same
price
across both gens but sony saying things
like demon souls
is going to be 70 which is like honestly
i was expecting it we haven't had a like
a
sharp hike in game costs in a long time
so i was very much anticipating that we
would be paying more per game
what is and we'll get into sony's
messaging around this event
in a minute because it's not really been
very
well delivered i would say but like how
is that going to work across like you
know horizon is going to be coming to
both platforms a lot of these games are
going to be coming to
both platforms i
if like jordan authority like if you're
playing that game on a
are you going to be playing on ps4 and
then just like i don't know paying extra
for ps5
it's a weird conversation about to say
it's
like you said we're going to go into
this a bit there's a messaging
problem here that sony and playstation
have where we just don't have
all the facts about how this is going to
work like i'm totally on board with
games costing 70 like you said like it's
been a
long time coming that we get a price
increase on
games but we don't know if like horizon
which releases on both ps4 and ps5 will
the ps4 version still be 60 will they
both be 70
will they both be 60 we don't know and
so it's just one of
those things that i'm kind of looking at
like ah it could fluctuate it could
change
who knows and so it's hard to have an
opinion on it since
sony is kind of really quiet about
all of this logistical information i
think to microsoft's credit though
the reason we're still kind of umming
annoying about
pricing is because they've basically
said that everything's gonna drop on
game pass
and so that's the reason that's not a
question that's been i mean it's a
question that's been asked surely but
it's not
a question that's kind of at the
forefront of everyone's minds whereas
sony has just kind of slipped out
oh yeah these games will be 70 dollars
um yeah and
the other thing is like smart delivery
helps ease a lot of things and smooths
over a lot of that stuff like a lot of
people will be thinking about if i buy
this game
here what got what happens with it and
the easy answer is look if it's got a
smart delivery if it does
um you're probably fine you're going to
get it on the next gen console
right now it's unclear one like the
price differential between
ps4 ps5 and two it's not clear whether
you buy one do you get it on the ps5 if
you buy on ps4
it doesn't seem like that's the case i
think what sony intends here is to just
support the previous generation which
makes sense given that
the the amount of units out there and
the amount of customers available to
them
is huge and not all of them they can't
count on moving over
so they want to present a cost more cost
effective tier for the people who don't
want to pay loads or don't want to jump
over immediately but also have that
more expensive slightly available um
option for others
i mean like you said we don't know if
horizon is going to cost the same across
the generations but
it's such a weird modeled situation that
it would be good to have some clarity
there
yes i completely agree all right let's
talk about launch
date so microsoft i feel so bad for them
like
they had like according to phil spencer
right it was supposed to
this was supposed to be their week and
then they just got late
and they kind of had to scramble and
kind of post everything up
you know in some cases at 6 a.m western
time but
we'll forgive them for that they had to
get all the info out there launch date
uh
for the xbox series x november 10th i
think in most regions
i do wonder if sony's november 12th is a
reaction
or if it was always supposed to be on
the 12th
however i like yeah i'm happy that it's
i'm happy that it's so close together
but i also
worry that i don't have time to play
everything
you're not gonna have enough time
regardless no playstation's gonna come
out like two weeks afterwards and we
would not have time to play
all the games that are coming to both
these consoles yeah i think i think the
timing is
i imagine like they
they didn't want to get beaten they
don't want to leave a large gap i don't
know i can't remember exactly but in the
uk i remember
there being a decent gap between me
getting a ps4 and then getting an xbox
one
and the xbox one was pretty hard to find
as well i remember
and i felt like a lot of people who are
waiting for the xbox one this is
anecdote also who knows like
i mean it's it's completely not
representative of how people behave but
like
you imagine that when people have the
option to get on the hype train that's
leaving now
or wait for the next one that's coming
in two or three weeks they're gonna get
on the one that's got seats because
their pals are on it and you know they
wanna jump or choo
i am obsessed with that uh analogy by
the way
uh you had me at like the seats on this
train
nice and warm like your friends are just
like pat in the comfy seat being like
join us
the train is leaving it's called a
playstation so you're like all right
well i guess i'll do it so i think
that's what they want to avoid they
don't want a long enough gap for people
to be like
i'm just going to buy what i got and
then you know they've spent the money
they would have spent on a
next-gen console this is close enough
that the people will wait obviously
and unfortunately for microsoft's case
like they probably would have liked
a little more space to breathe and i
imagine even sony would have liked a
little more space to breathe but
the toss-up is do we like let a bunch of
customers potentially take the plunge
before
the your release that comes around or we
just like make it a bit messier for
everyone
and i think they probably pick the right
one i mean it's a very strategic
placement like by putting it on the 12th
like xbox can claim like if you want to
play assassin's creed
valhalla next gen first like you have to
play it on
xbox but like they don't get access to
things like cyberpunk 2077 like
playstation be like oh no you can play
that game on our next gen console via
backwards compatibility too
assuming that's the case honestly is
messy and chaotic and i kind of love it
i i like
you don't get scraps like this really at
any other point in the year so i'm kind
of
into it but i i you know
pouring one out for uk europe
uh south america middle east
asia and south africa who have to wait
till the 19th um
i remember being on the other side of
that before i moved to america for the
ps4
and it does suck and i'm
sorry usa i got my i got my xbox
uh one from a pop-up store that appeared
in
trafalgar square and i like rolled up
and there was a line and i'm gonna
and like i i walked i walked towards the
towards the actual entrance and
i didn't see the line until the very
last second
like and like i was foot the guy the guy
whose security was letting me in
and then as i was like saying thanks to
him i saw a line
and i had my moment where i was like i
can either be the good guy here and get
in line or i can be an [ __ ]
let me tell you i went up those stairs
so fast you would not believe
my man i sprinted up those stairs i was
like
see you suckers
yeah no i was gonna say so i feel bad
like because sony
um i'm not doing a worldwide release
date and microsoft ah
so obviously we've been watching we've
watched the convention on like
convention press conference digital
event whatever the hell you want to call
it we're watching it on us time and so
everyone over here is like
hey that's great november 10th and i
just imagine waking up tomorrow morning
to see all my uk
pals being like well this sucks
and on top of that a lot of the
pre-orders in uk on uk sites are alive
so some of them probably like wake up in
the morning and be like what it already
happened they're all sold out oh i
missed it
yeah so it's like a twilight zone
episode
but yeah pre-ordering just in general
we're recording this for contacts on
wednesday
evan my fave my boy can you please
insert the clip
of the jeff keeley interview when sony
say you will have
advanced warning on how to pre-order
your console
please we'll let you know when
pre-order will happen we will you know
it's not going to happen with a minute's
notice we're
going to at some point let you know when
you can pre-order a playstation 5.
so um please don't feel like you have to
go run out
and and line up anywhere until you
receive official notice on how that'll
work
yep that's me you're probably wondering
how i ended up in this situation
yeah it's been kind of a mess retailers
like huge like massive behavior coming
from walmart by the way
tweeted sony playstation's tweet which
was like
oh preorders are coming tomorrow and
then walmart just
caught it it's quite big like you know
that let people like things where the
guy is like holding the lips closed
yeah like it's got that energy
actually if you stick around to the end
of this video uh we
were having a planning meeting about
this episode and you can see us
uh pre-order our consoles
[Laughter]
while a bunch of people getting that is
cancelled so you know touch word fingers
crossed everything goes through but who
the hell knows
um spin i i imagine like xbox's leak
last week has thrown everything off and
like
lining up all these retailers must be an
absolute
nightmare so kind of forgive him for it
but at the same time
it's 20 20. we should be better at this
okay yes a time to discuss the games
themselves in terms of launch lineup so
we've got the ps5 launch
um assassin's creed valhalla astros
playroom
demon souls and we'll come back to that
in a minute
destruction all stars definitely cry 5
special edition fortnite
marvel spider-man miles morales and sack
boy a big adventure xbox i mean in the
meanwhile has assassin's creed valhalla
dirt 5 fifa
fortnight gears 5 gears tactics avengers
nba tetris effect falconer watch dogs
legion and yakuza
um so i assume yeah yeah we've got we
should have um
watch dogs on ps5 too um
so that's in terms of like ps5 games you
also got the playstation plus
collection so games like battlefield
batman
days gone uncharted god of war
bloodborne oh baby
let's go do you have something to say
tonight
not like a perfect counter to game pass
but
playstation plush collection is pretty
it's pretty much
it's pretty deep list i'm not a petty
man
i'm not dishonest ignore the thing i
said earlier about cutting the line
together um and i'm not a petty man
but i think someone owes me two
apologies
two two apologies two yeah
because one was a certain game i said
would be there at launch
and then the other one i was talking
about bloodborne being uh being
available and you're like wishful
thinking my friend
i do not remember the second one at all
uh
evan cut the first one in and then
manipulate that so that it sounds like
he's
wrong to me a second time
[Laughter]
okay well first of all that's the
literal definition of fake news you
can't
use video editing to manipulate
jordan's saying something some people
some people were saying some people have
said
that jordan some people who are these
are these people is this is this her too
saying
[Laughter]
court is now in session what is
the dream launch exclusive time will
come to you first
i'm gonna pick a game that doesn't have
a release date but has been in
development for
quite a while if rumors are to be
believed um
i'm gonna pick from software
and blue point games is demon souls
remake
this is a shocking wildlife either elden
ring
or demon souls remake is coming out i
didn't say
it's definitely coming out this year let
me dream
i am your giants are unrealistic tam
what's what's your wild card prediction
you know what my world calculation is
there is baby it's bloodborne it's back
for episode two
i will take i will say jordan's jordan's
pick is actually probably what
uh i'm super excited about but in my
heart
if they just put out a little little it
be patch for me
i'd be very happy just improve the
loading times maybe stabilize the frame
rate in some areas and you just make
the the perfect version of bloodborne
that's the perfect version of the
perfect game
jordan overwatch and bloodborne who
could have possibly predicted that you
two would take the pistol
i judge the defendant innocent and
correct only one apology must be issued
i say your piece no i'm cool i don't
need it i i'd like to
i'll just bask in my victory in my maybe
demon souls will be
delayed and i can still be right
now you're just wishing ill upon us all
wow
uh honestly so i think a pretty
like an exciting lineup for both
consoles i think playstation
uh coming out the woodwork with that
kind of alternative to playstation plus
great call they have some fantastic
games on there like
yes god of course i'm gonna play
bloodborne on playstation five that's a
no-brainer the one thing i would have
liked to have known about the
playstation pro
playstation plus collection one thing
i'll bloody say about this gem right
everything is so hard to say
alliteration everyone that was like that
was the same energy as telling a kid off
and then turning to your friend and
being like
anthony you put that down one thing i
say about having kids is they actually
disgust me jim
ryan mark
if i have to like that's that's the vibe
i'm gonna come with the
uh angry mother angry brother like it's
too difficult to say
anyway i would have liked some
clarification i'm
purposefully over enunciating like some
clarification
on what these games are going to be like
when they're on the playstation 5
are they upscaling anyway any
improvements being made or is it just
emulating playstation 4 architecture and
that's it
so that's what i want to know the weird
thing is like
they they specifically said a certain
like a hundred or so whatever games will
be
available to play backwards comparable
which
leads us to believe that they are having
to do work to them to make them
comparable
which yeah yeah but surely that means
like if they're doing that work to make
it work on
the that console surely it means that
they're also doing the work to make sure
it work
leverages what the console does a bit
more again maybe this is me overthinking
and being
wishful thinking but like i would hope
that the fact that they chose these
games to bring over also means they
chose these games to improve slightly
be it quicker loading times just the
baseline what the ps5 can do should
improve what they are if they just roll
up being
like exactly as they are and still like
same load time same frame rate whatever
i'll take it because you know most of
those games function perfectly fine on a
ps4
but if they do go the extra mile that
would be way more beneficial
i i agree i just i i want to know and i
also want to know if my ps4 subscription
is going to cost
more um but in terms of launch titles
i think you know obviously bolstered by
third
party devil may cry is a good get for
sony
um i think miles morales another
fantastic one but like
yeah the game the game that's got my
attention there is demon souls
um yeah it's i was surprised about
ratchet and clank though i'm not gonna
lie
given that ratchet and clang seems to be
the game like the ps5 game we've seen
the most of
um yeah i was kind of expecting them to
at least confirm whether it's coming
this year
or 2021 since they keep using that vague
launch window knowledge yeah it's like
you keep using that word
i think they need to keep some ammo in
the clip for later on like a little
closer to the time like you never know
like as as the release date approaches
they could pop up and say oh
so these games are going to be available
um but
it's like we talked about during the
live stream uh pre-show is
i think they want a certain number of
games to kind of like
be the next step in that relay race of
keeping the momentum going
so we've got like these these initial
launch titles that you mentioned
and i imagine they're going to space it
out or i hope that they're thinking
about spacing it out so that once the
momentum on that starts to dip
they come in with we've got ratchet and
clank we've got gran turismo seven we've
got
x y and z um and you're good to go i
mean one thing
to definitely talk about is uh you
mentioned 2021 there
obviously things have slips uh kana
i never pronounced that right is that
right i
i cannot tell you kenya
anya kenya anya kenny
kenna kenna
i cannot
um has obviously slipped death loop has
slipped
but i think in the playstation
conference we had today it was a really
nice look at
yes you get this stuff at launch but
this is the stuff to look forward to
next year i mean like do you remember
when blizzard announced
well everyone thought they were going to
announce diablo 4 and they announced the
diablo
moment is this uh an out of season
april fool's joke
uh no it's it's a
it's a fully uh fully fledged uh diablo
experience
on on mobile and i think we all remember
that i remember at the time
talking back at the office like we were
all just like
they could have just released a logo
people would have been
fine big big vibes from god of war 2
there it was like literally like a logo
a bit of voiceover a bit of music
but still i had the chills and and then
i saw the release date of like 20 21 i
was like oh
okay yeah okay i mean so i'm you you're
getting me in
at the first day with like mars morales
and demon souls but if i've got
horizon to look forward to god of war to
look forward to as well as other things
like
stray returnal death loop uh ghostway
tokyo
even though we didn't see all of them
this week i did like that a lot of the
games they had
i mean final fantasy as well that is the
game that we'll see in five years time
because that is how square enix likes to
announce
games but like the promise that it will
be there eventually
that really gets to me as a playstation
exclusive as well
that's wild wild and the god of war
thing is really interesting because no
one's actually said god of war
ii right like or a sequel to god of war
i mean like no spoils for the ending of
god of war but like if you try to do the
credits it was
clear it was implied yeah but also like
uh
i i kind of like there's a part of my
mind that
thinks that this might be a miles
morales situation for god of war
where it's it's kind of like a not not a
full full whole you know hog news
entry in the game but something that
takes the original game
builds upon it to do something new and
and present a you know a different
a new fresh experience but that doesn't
require the same kind of commitment
resources and time to develop a brand
new game because it feels quite too
quick to be a brand new entry in that
franchise
and especially given how much effort
they put in and that game
was basically crammed into the ps4 as
most modern
ps4 games are so i imagine like with a
little more breathing room
that engine and the team the thing that
that team can do will absolutely
like soar but i feel like it's not going
to be
like maybe i'm i i suspect and i hope
improvement not a helper program but i
suspect that it might be a kind of miles
morale situation where it's like we've
got a big expansion thing that you can
buy standalone here
and it's that's why it's out so soon
i don't know i mean by the time like
sony santa monica are really stuffing up
right now
by the time this game's come out i
imagine it'll be holiday next year i
don't think it's going to go for the
same
4 20. i remember i will never forget the
god of war came out on 4
20. um uh
i imagine it's gonna be a holiday next
year i think they have
the time for it to be a full sequel
because they had so they
built it i think they future-proofed
very well
yeah in god of war uh 2018 and i feel
like god of war 2021
god of war ragnarok god of war two god
of war 1.5 whatever we want to call it
um i think it's gonna be a full sequel i
yeah i would i mean like either way i'm
more than happy to have it like
very excited about having more god of
war i'd love to see
my my my thinking is basically to scale
expectation on narrative more than
anything else
just because i'm like i want to see what
because i love that franchise
so i'm wondering if it's going to be
like a small story or a massive story
again
i'd love to have that massive story all
over again just message corey
i'll do that yeah all right so that was
kind of our rundown of the uh the ps5
event from this week
i will put the question to you both
i don't want to do like the verses but
like have they done enough
and are they i think are sony in the
position that they need to be
in going into the launch of the
playstation 5. jordan will come to you
first
it's one of those things that i think
yes they're in a pretty good spot it's
one of those
really weird things that a lot of those
upcoming first party exclusives that
we're looking forward to for both xbox
and playstation are now coming in
2021 so the launch lineups for both of
these consoles are filled with a lot of
third-party games but considering
that they are launching alongside the
series x which is coming in
strong with game pass ultimate
having a ps5 exclusive like demon souls
and even if you can't play it on ps4
having something like
miles morales as well as having all of
these
awesome ps4 titles that you can go back
and play i think we'll do a really good
job just to
move systems to get to 2021 where we'll
see
death loop and horizon and god of war
and all of those
games that people are waiting for so i
think they've done enough i think that
they've done
actually probably more than enough to
stay competitive with xbox for the rest
of
2020 early 2021. tim what about you
yeah it's like you said like we're not
we're not a
team or a website or a show specifically
that likes to pit one against the other
and i think i want to take that same
kind of approach to this like
i think sony's done an amazing job and i
think the only reason that we got this
thing
the amazing like a press conference
style uh
slash um showcase that we got today is
because microsoft
did made it so they had to do that
microsoft was so strong in what they
showed off
um between the pricing the way they've
talked up game pass which is exactly
what they say
is it is some of the best value in
gaming around
um and that has kind of pushed sony to
do you know everything they need to and
they had to
to one make the console an attractive
price to show off some big big games
and you know there's always discussions
about fanboy wars and
for the most part they suck and they're
pointless but the one thing you can
you can say is like this kind of rivalry
breeds competition and this is the case
where it's come out for the better i
think
whether you're getting xbox series xs or
you're getting a playstation 5
uh either of the two skus you're getting
a pretty fantastic console out of this
and you're gonna have some amazing
gaming experiences
available to you day one so did sony do
enough i think sony did enough to show
that anyone who
purchases purchases the console on day
one will be satisfied and will have
plenty of options to them
and in the same way microsoft has done
the same if you pick up a
xbox on day one you'll be not paying
that much
and you'll have game pass available to
you and you'll have loads of
upcoming blockbuster games available to
you and it's going to be great
yeah and i mean i think it's very weird
because gaming
still seems very in the grand scheme of
what's happening in the world
it still doesn't feel like it i mean it
is so important but also it doesn't feel
like it is the most important thing but
it's like
in a sliding doors opportunity
i got i wonder what this year would have
looked like
if the world hadn't gone to
like i i mean i
i can't even imagine the amount of
pivoting
last decisions that have gone into
pretty much every aspect of
uh like playstation and xbox's strategy
this year and i just think
it's kind of still amazing that we're
even getting consoles and
games at launch and games at all like at
all
so yeah because a bunch of games have
been delayed because of
what's going on in the world so probably
at one point series
x and ps5 their launch lineups were a
bit more stacked
um yeah and i just i just want to
clarify that
you know the stuff we i said about
fanboyism and that kind of stuff is
ridiculous but
the playstation has demonstrated once
better later
all right let's see i thought we said no
competition damn
that seems the goodest places the week
uh jordan where can people find you you
can find me on twitter at jmramy
uh i am on twitter at tomorrow h still
absolutely quivering
it's okay there's always next year all
right uh and i'm on twitter these james
games we'll see you next week
bye bye i hope my pre-order hasn't been
canceled
oh damn yeah
oh they're up at walmart it says it's on
back order the digital edition's there
though
oh yeah i've got digital i think the
link is just broken it dies in the cart
apparently
mine hasn't died the page the page seems
to have died now for
me so i think it's crashing
yeah item is unavailable back order
place order no it says no longer
available
so for the next 24 hours i'm not gonna
sleep and i'm just going to like
keep refreshing all the walmart game
stop target best buy pages over
and over again yeah
what i'll go on let's
go playstation why do you hate me is it
because
i like xbox so much is that the only
reason
it seems like such a silly reason
walmart has tweeted
[Music]
wow
tomorrow walmart's just gone
wow amazing i'd love to see it
oh there it is come on don't wait with
me
digital digital's back up now walmart
it's just the one that everyone wants oh
disc one's up
pages up disc one i'm wondering if i
should pre-order that as well
i'm glad i got one